The joe rogan experience and I,
and I'm not going to be because I tried,
uh,
we eat yeah.
Once two years ago and I stayed hide for 14 days straight to God,
man.
Did you eat it?
14 days.
900 he smoked.
He wasn't a vaporizer.
Is that,
yeah.
Vaporize vaporizer.
Yeah.
And I say hi for 14 days and I thought it doesn't right.
He doesn't,
I wasn't high.
Right.
Well hopefully it wasn't,
but I thought it was like disconnected from reality.
Well sometimes that does happen and I know a story about a guy who is a straight
laced guy who took some marijuana edible so that he could get to sleep and he
had a real problem.
Like he got suicidal and freaked out and became just irrationally anxious.
He had crippling anxiety and some time for some time for weeks.
And he's a confident guy and a very handsome,
big muscular guy.
Like he just like,
you would never imagine this guy have any antianxiety.
I think some people have just the chemistry of different individuals.
I wasn't bar for death and that's what the doctor told me because I went to the
psychiatrist.
Wow,
you went to this like
I swear to God,
I'm dead week.
That week I went to the psych guy through smell and I told him no,
I smoked that thing like 14 days ago and I still high.
And he,
he looked at me and he gave me some,
some cycle one.
He gave me some pills and I was like,
Oh,
if you stay high until tomorrow,
take these pills.
Because what he told me,
it's something that I didn't know that he can be a trigger if you're has some
tennis of schizophrenia and a psychopath or if you feel have,
which was not my case.
And He's told this is very rare,
but he can't happen,
which is not your case.
And I,
it was happy because of the up and the next day I was okay and I felt okay and I
did it took the pills and it was crazy,
man.
It's crazy.
And I remember that I decided to record it,
but I was like,
like,
Hey,
let me,
let me record what I'm thinking.
At least let's get some good experience out of it.
And I remember that it started to record and I said,
uh,
now I'm going to record everything that I'm thinking.
And when I look at the cell phone,
it was 45 minutes,
45 minutes to talk.
And I didn't even realize I just said that I'm going to record now.
And there was 45 minutes and when I listened to like 15 days after that,
I was like,
I'm so crazy.
So crazy.
I'm going to die.
I'm never going to understand on my son's talking,
talking to me right now.
Wow.
That was one hit of available.
No,
it was more than one.
A bunch of hits.
He was a bunch.
Oh,
you're too tall.
You're big.
You're like a 250 pounds.
So fucking use it a lot.
Oh,
so they were saying keep hitting it because you're tall.
Because I wasn't feeling it.
Oh No.
But when I felt it,
I felt for 14 and you know,
having that belief does,
does add up to that.
I mean that's step one in my opinion is visualize a nam believing it and on the
flip side,
having a negative self worth or a negative opinion of what you're about to do or
a negative thought about the future can also manifest all sorts of terrible
results.
Absolutely.
Gotta think placebo effect is a real thing.
We know that,
right?
We know that if you really do believe that you're going to get better because of
some sugar pill they give you,
there's a tangible result,
100% if you really believe that salt guy,
if the thing about all that stupid shit is,
if you believe it,
it actually has an effect.
There's,
there's a lot of healers out there that at least on paper are totally full of
shit.
But if you believe in these assholes,
yeah,
I can make a difference.
It's very slippery.
The human mind is such a slippery thing.
I mean,
and I'll go back to my own experience and again,
I don't know how a femoral are out there you want to get,
but I'm out there in Antarctica 54 days alone.
Like I'm telling you I'm doing this for this bigger purpose.
I'm feel like I'm tapped into that and like legitimately there were moments,
at least for me,
whether I'm manifesting that in my mind,
whatever you want to call it,
that I am actually feeling energetically uplifted by the people pushing me on.
Like there were days that were incredibly hard where I would sit there and I'd
be like,
oh my God,
I don't know if I can do this and I'm done.
Like boom.
Like I would get over,
I would hit with this sort of larger purpose,
that's larger outcome and again,
like I'm not,
I'm not a super religious person.
I was actually raised on a hippie commune.
Like I come from a pretty untraditional background,
but like the energetic field,
whatever you want to call that or if that's just the belief in something,
you know,
the power of that.
Like I felt the strength from those moments.
There was moments when my body's switched from kind of being negative.
Oh my God,
another hard day out here.
it's minus 25 to tapping into those flow states.
So again,
I don't,
I don't have perfect words for that.
Um,
you know,
I'm starting to try to build my vocabulary around that.
But that energy,
I think it was derived from what you're saying.
If you start to believe it,
if you can believe like,
hey,
there's a larger purpose in this,
or hey,
this blue force fields A's and one foot,
there is something that if you can originate that positivity in your mind that I
think can give us incredible amounts of strength,
um,
and,
and then we can tap into something greater.
And so imagine being this guy getting medals and awards for helping create jobs
around the country and then realizing that automation is coming like a tidal
wave and that your efforts that you're getting applauded for really not going to
do the trick.
And then Donald Trump wins the election in 2016 and for whatever reason,
in my opinion,
the media is just not being honest about all the economic drivers.
They're blaming racism,
Russia base book,
the FBI.
And if you look at the voter district data on a district by district basis,
there's a straight line up between the adoption of industrial robots in that
voting district and the movement towards Trump.
Like it's a straight economic story where we blasted away 4 million jobs in the
swing states and Donald Trump is our president.
So imagine being me and then seeing that and being like,
okay,
I get it.
This is an economic,
technological story.
And then I went to people in Washington DC.
I was like,
hey guys,
what are we going to do?
We're in the third inning of the greatest economic and technological
transformation in the history of our country.
And the third inning has brought us Donald Trump.
The fourth,
fifth,
sixth endings are going to be horrific.
What are we going to do?
And then the answers I got were somewhere between disappointing and horrifying,
where if you go to mainstream politicians and you're like,
what are we going to do?
The answers I got were literally number one.
We cannot talk about that.
Number two,
we should study that.
We cannot talk about that.
That was,
that's verbatim really.
Yeah.
And why were they saying that?
Because it seems alarmists like anti progress or like,
you know,
you're like,
uh,
you know,
throwing stones at like,
like big tech companies and it's like,
I'm not throwing stones at anyone.
I'm just pointing out the fact.
So number one is,
uh,
so number one was can't talk about it.
Number two was need to study it.
And the number three was the point you made a originally,
which was we must educate and retrain Americans for the jobs of the future.
And then when I was like,
Hey,
we're terrible at that by the numbers,
then they'd literally be like,
well,
I guess we'll learn to get better at it then.
And then I,
so I came back to my home in New York City and I was like,
oh my gosh,
we are so backward and far gone as a,
certainly as a government.
Um,
and so then I was grappling with it and I'm a parent like you are.
And I looked at my kids and I was like,
am I really going to bring them up in this shit show?
Like,
is this really the,
is this really the plan?
And so then I was like,
okay,
how would you actually solve this problem if you,
if you had to do so?
And so then I said,
okay,
universal basic income,
rebranded the freedom dividend after we did a bunch of tests because it tests
much better as the freedom dividend and universal basic income and,
and then try and make the,
the rules of the economy work better for more people as fast as we can before
this automation wave really crescendo.
And then,
uh,
okay,
sure.
Um,
and then Alzheimer's,
you know,
uh,
again,
I know you're plus a plus 50,
so you know,
cheeks see Saint Jo has alzheimers.
I know that he wants to keep doing this podcast for forever.
That'd be excused to stuff.
So,
so THC has been shown to inhibit the formation of Beta amyloid plaques.
That's the,
you know,
the hallmark of Alzheimer's disease.
And then CBD CBD has also been shown to be effective for um,
for Alzheimer's disease as well.
It was a rat study that was going to,
um,
get into,
but it's fairly fairly,
it's fairly detailed.
So you know,
it might be best just to say that it can,
you know,
help with rescue memory in patients if you do use CBD meaning and that it may
actually reverse and that's been shown before to,
they've done that in mice.
I got to interrupt you for one second.
Okay.
And I think you would agree this data is,
some of it's,
some of it sort of epidemiological,
some of it's preclinical,
it's very,
very early.
None of it really proves game and just let me say I'm a clinician.
Okay.
If someone comes to me and they have a concussion,
it's very frustrating just to say to them,
hey,
physical,
cognitive,
rest,
go home.
Okay.
It's really frustrating to say that to someone also to,
you know,
the uh,
the high fat diet thing.
You know,
Joe and I both fall,
you know,
very,
very similar die.
So that's something I wanted to share with regards to,
you know,
the,
the Alzheimer's disease,
we have really,
really poor medications for that and we have an aging population.
So again,
like Alex,
like you want to look at everything,
which is what I'm doing.
Like I'm looking at everything and I'm trying to make a clinical decision.
Am I using some things like without,
you know,
randomized control trials?
Of course I am.
But again,
I'm a clinician so I'm using,
you know,
mechanisms of action.
I'm using what I've see and clinic and I'm using epidemiological studies and I'm
also taking into account what other medicines do I have your base upon all the
data.
This seems to be an effective treatment and I am absolutely not saying that you
as a clinician shouldn't do that.
Especially you're in Canada at t cannabis is legal.
You should,
you should use your best judgment.
What I'm saying is that when we're talking about policy decisions around
cannabis and Thc,
and to a much lesser extent,
CBD,
the advocacy groups have seized on this very,
very preliminary data to to say a lot of things about cannabis and THC that have
not been proven.
And you know,
a guy I know named Peter Bock,
who very smart,
uh,
he's a pulmonologist,
is at Memorial Sloan Kettering in New York and he wrote a piece in the Wall
Street Journal,
a few,
Oh,
a couple of weeks ago talking about cannabis is limits as medicine.
And he said something that I thought it was so well put,
which is the reason why people want cannabis to work for Alzheimer's and cancer
and a bunch of things.
Where does,
where there's really no evidence that it works is that we don't have good
treatments.
We want cures.
We want help.
We,
if we're clinicians,
I mean,
I'm not a clinician.
You're a clinician.
Want to be able to give people who come into our offices something.
But that hope is not a substitute for science.
It doesn't mean that it works.
And even you want,
you want your patients to have hope.
Okay.
But the advocates,
the people,
we're using this to push,
especially to push THC and to capitalize on the public confusion around THC and
CBD.
I think that is a real,
it's a real
disservice to people.
Okay.
Um,
listen,
uh,
I think we covered everything.
So it's a complicated subject.
It really is.
And a,
I think it's really important to discuss how complicated it is.
I don't,
I don't think there's a,
I've never heard such a detailed analysis of all this stuff in,
in a way where you can get two opposing people that are,
you know,
very civil about it,
but agree on certain aspects of it.
I think.
I think we really highlighted all those things.